you talked about being in a relationship
what role Jimmy does love playing The
Human Condition
I think
what role does well the big thing is
love can be scary because this is you
know the human you're gonna spend the
most amount of time with in your life
you know and so for project that over 50
years they can be a liability or an
asset love the magic tricks you know I
love no but seriously it's got to be
someone that makes you better for me I
can't truly love someone that doesn't
make me better because yeah in the long
run yeah across across because if not
then it's like it's a negative you know
to everything I spent my life building
yeah um but luckily I'm very happy with
the the partner I haven't like we were
talking about before I do think she
makes me better there's a lot of
actually positives I've noticed even
things as simple as like you know I
struggle to turn off my brain at night
because I'm just thinking about all the
businesses and how we could do better or
whatever weird thing I have on my mind
but you know just chatting with her and
hanging out with her helps me like
basically just shut my brain off and
like mellow out and even like there's
just a ton of little things like that
that I've noticed are positives
especially when you really look for them
that are easy to gloss over if you're
not
um and so for me yeah I have someone who
I think it's very beautiful very
intelligent makes me better it's
constantly pushing me okay with me
working hard makes me smarter and just
all these different things that I think
for me love
just makes me a better person you know
what I mean which makes me love her even
more does that make sense absolutely
what advice would you give on uh finding
somebody like that
um
just really don't give up until you you
find someone that you know that there's
so many people on the planet I mean
there really is there there's billions
of the odds are in your favor of yeah
like just don't settle and find someone
that you know makes you happy
yeah just like you said surround
yourself with people the that make you a
better person in the same case surround
yourself with that one special person
that really makes you a better person
and for and maybe that's just an
entrepreneurial brain looking at it not
everyone wants to hyper optimize their
life like me but for me to like truly
love someone they have to make me a
better person in every way yeah yeah